صدق أو لا تصدق ، قد يكون برازنا
أحد أفضل آمالنا في الكشف السريع عن
تفشي فيروس كورونا لأن
المرض يمكن اكتشافه في البراز حتى
قبل أن يخضع الناس لاختبارات فيروس كورونا.
في منتصف
تجربة ضخمة ، نأمل في العثور على
فاشيات جديدة بسرعة من خلال العثور على الفيروس في
مياه الصرف الصحي إذا كان من الممكن
الحصول على فكرة عن تركيز
الفيروس التاجي في مياه الصرف الصحي ، يمكننا
حساب عدد الأشخاص المصابين
بشكل منطقي وهذا سيكون
مثيرة للاهتمام للغاية في استراتيجيات فيروس كورونا ،
ألمانيا من بين العديد من
البلدان التي تجري تجارب لمعرفة ما إذا كان
يمكن أن تكون مياه الصرف الصحي عبارة عن نظام إنذار مبكر ، اكتشف الباحثون 19 في وقت
مبكر جدًا
أثناء الوباء أنه يمكن بالفعل تتبع kovat 19
في البراز ولكن السؤال الكبير الآن
هو هل يمكن ذلك  يتم إجراؤها على
أساس آلي منتظم ويمكن أن يتم
ذلك في منطقة كبيرة مثل
بلد بأكمله على سبيل المثال  أكبر مشكلة في
العثور على آثار صغيرة للفيروس
في الكثير من الحمأة مثل هذا في
مركز هيلمهولتز الشهير
للدراسات البيئية يحاول علماء الأحياء لاني
كيليس القيام بذلك
بهدف استخراج أجزاء من جينوم الفيروس
تسمى الحمض النووي الريبي من عينات كبيرة من
مياه الصرف الصحي  لدينا حجم كبير من
مياه الصرف الصحي وأعتقد أنه من
الصعب العثور على آثار
الفيروس في مياه الصرف الصحي ، لذلك لدينا
لترات وعلينا
تقليصها إلى ميكرولتر للحصول على كمية
كافية لأي عملية استخراج
أعتقد أن هذا  تحدٍ إذا
نجحوا في المستقبل في حدوث ارتفاعات مفاجئة لفيروس
كورونا وعينات من بعض
محطات الصرف الصحي يمكن أن تخبر السلطات
بمكان حدوث حالات تفشي جديدة
وتسمح لهم بالتفاعل بسرعة
يخبرني أحد رؤساء الدراسة أنه
سيكون أول اختبار يبدأ به  من خلال
قياسنا ومن ثم ستعرف
إلى أين تذهب للبحث عن الأسباب
مع أن سلطات المعرفة يمكن
أن تبدأ بعد ذلك اختبارًا مستهدفًا
يقول العلماء إن نموذجهم يمكن أن يكون
جاهزًا للنشر ، عندما
تضرب الموجة التالية من فيروس كورونا الجديد
، أعتقد أنه يمكننا تقديم شيء ما قبل
الموجة التالية في الواقع ، لذا إذا كانت
الموجة التالية قادمة في الخريف أو مبكرًا.
في فصل الشتاء أو نحو ذلك ، يجب أن يكون لدينا
شيء يقر العلماء
أنه لا يزال أمامهم طريق طويل وصعب ،
لكنهم واثقون من أنهم قد
يجدون بالفعل طريقة لجعل البراز في
إنذار فيروس كورونا الطبيعي فريد بيكين
سي إن إن لايبزيغ ألمانيا